hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
September is upon us and all my gosh
some of the biggest releases of the year
are dropping this month so if your bank
balance has the funds mine doesn't
here's nine great games you should play
this month oh and do me a favor help me
decide which game I should play here on
the channel thanks very much we have to
start with the game of the month for
most people well most people who have a
ps4 as Marvel spider-man is exclusive to
the PlayStation 4 I'm sure you've seen
countless videos about spider-man and
those previews have all but guaranteed
this is game of the year quality in
addition to playing as the webslinger
will also be sleuthing with Mary Jane
Watson who in this universe is a
journalist and will also play as Peter
without the glamourous spandex as he
lives his life as a budding scientist
the team behind Marvel spider-man is
none other than insomniac the same guys
who made Ratchet and Clank resistance
spyro and sunset overdrive spider-man on
ps4 is going to be epic
releasing on Friday September the 7th
back in 2012
Telltale Games released The Walking Dead
video game it was an episodic adventure
which focused on Lee and his father like
relationship with Clementine whose
parents were probably eaten to death by
a zombie horde by the end of the season
Clementine was close to our hearts and
by the time season 2 ended in 2014 she
had grown into a zombie slaying badass
now 80 is on from our first meeting the
final season of The Walking Dead has
begun and after last month's slow
opening episode Clem is back in episode
to suffer the children this season looks
to be about Clem raising AJ and teaching
him how to be a man in this new zombie
filled world episode 2 releases on
September the 25th as we're already
talking about episodic adventures let's
look at life is strange - which releases
on September the 27th in many ways it
plays the same as the tell-tale games
it's like a choose your own adventure
story but life is strange has a trick up
its sleeve a car mechanic - the game is
rewind which gives the player the
ability to go back in time and undo any
actions which have affected the
storyline it's like the butterfly effect
to see how a decision could pan out and
then deciding we don't like this and
going back and trying it another way
life is strange to has a demo game you
can try right now search for The Amazing
Adventures of Captain Spirit on your
platform of choice to play the games
teaser starring a new character and his
dad episode 1 of life is strange 2 will
be downloadable from September the 27th
there's three sports titles dropping in
September let's class them as one entry
EA SPORTS FIFA 19 NBA 2k 19 and NHL 19
all make their annual returns this month
all have updated rosters and licenses
and subtle changes to gameplay which
will only be noticeable by those who
play regularly every year there'll be a
demo version of all three games
available to you to try out before
jumping into the full versions but let's
start an argument to which spot is
better football soccer basketball or
hockey I'll put a poll on-screen let's
see who wins
moving on to some more action the Tomb
Raider reboot series continues this
month with shadow of the Tomb Raider
it's the sequel to 2013's Tomb Raider
and 2015's rise of the Tomb Raider and
follows the narrative from those two
outings once again we take control of
Lara Croft who is out doing a spot of
archeology when she accidentally
activates the apocalypse if I had a
dollar for every apocalypse I
accidentally started like always Lara is
driven by the memory over her late
father and his mysterious lifestyle
shadow of the Tomb Raider drops on
September the 14th ok the last two games
on the list ant brand-spanking-new games
but expansions or extensions if you will
destiny two's forsaken DLC appears this
month and hopes to revitalize the game
which has struggled over the last eight
months if you're on PS plus you can
download the base game right now for
free to try out the improvement made
recently there's also a free 24 hour
period to try out the brand-spanking-new
gambit mode for destiny 2 which has
received pretty damn good reviews so if
you fancy a little space travel across
lush green land and militarized
planetoids with ample loot grinding all
wrapped up in the solid first-person
shooter maybe just maybe destiny 2 could
be the game for you the forsaken DLC
will be downloadable from September the
4th and finally fortnight
I'm still bloody addicted to it at the
end of September we can expect season 6
to begin in the game we're currently
watching a mythical tesseract cube
rolling around the map in the hopes of
predicting the next season of content
what we can say for certain is that the
map will continue to evolve and a brand
new battle fast will arrive with new
emote skins and collectible items to
grind for and those of you who don't
like fortnight don't worry it won't be
here forever enjoy it while you can so
there we have it 9 new or updated games
to play during September 2018 what are
you grabbing and what do you think I
should play here on the channel
spider-man right it has to be spider-man
I'd love to know your thoughts I'm
Madeleine from PlayStation grenade it's
been a bloody pleasure I'll see you next
time
[Music]